today we're going to be speaking with
anthony barnett who's a founder of the
london-based global website open
democracy and has also just published
taking control humanity and america
after trump and the pandemic
anthony really great to have you on very
good to be with you david so i mean tell
us what what's the main premise what's
the big change that you're looking at
now in this post-trump at least for now
and maybe getting to post pandemic
although not really and it's sort of a
question mark but at least out of the
initial stages of it what what is
materially changed in your mind yeah
well you're right to say post trump
right for now because i found two things
really surprising about what happened uh
uh when i asked when i was watching the
january 6 event and afterwards because
when it happened i thought trump is
finished and the first shock was the way
in which the republican party rallied to
his support
and i think what this means is that if
he comes back
or if a trump-like supporter right
desantis comes back
it will be the closest thing to fascism
that i have ever expected in my lifetime
what i call modern factions it won't be
nazis it might be expansionist
but they their calling card is now to
break the rules to break this sense of
consent and in effect implement a form
of white supremacy and this is really
dangerous not just for america but for
all of us around the world so that was
my first shock and the second one was a
different kind of surprise which was
when
biden became president and he thanked
explicitly bernie sanders and the bernie
sanders movement and he reached out to
progressives in a constructive fashion
and that proved very popular and in
terms of my lifetime i've lived under uh
since you know the beginning i mean i
remember reagan and thatcher and since
the beginning of what you might call
some money monetary monetism that that
sense that the government is the problem
and the market knows the solution
progressives like myself have been
pushed to the margins there's been it's
been a
sense of saying you've you know you've
got to accept the market there was a
propagation of what i call fatalism in
the book and oddly enough trump broke
fatalism he made voting count he
empowered his followers
and at the beginning of the biden
presidency there was a sense of uh an
intelligent empowerment taking place as
a counterweight and i thought that that
is historic what you're doing in america
the potential i know everybody in
america at the moment all progressing
them are feeling very down there's the
supreme court decisions are making it
even worse there's a sense of pessimism
in the air
but the thing is biden won with a seven
million plurality
trump got the largest vote any sitting
president ever got in history got four
and a half million more votes than obama
did and obama got
69.5 million the largest ever trump got
74 million and then got 81 million
so we if i can put it like that we
progressives are the majority we've got
to get our act together the system is
rigged against us
and and so i felt we had to address this
and the question i asked myself
is what given the defeat of the left
given the defeat of progressives
given the defeating effect of the
socialist argument of the trade union
movement
why are progressives so strong how come
there was a seven million
majority
what is the strength i can understand
the weaknesses and then i look to this
question of what i call the humanization
it's feminism black lives matter human
rights underneath marketization all
these forces against the market were
growing and i think that
from the point of view whether it's
putin or whether it's trump uh that's
the or she in china or modi in india
that's their threat they're there they
understand the threat of real democracy
uh in a way that the
i think that the leadership of the
progressive movement certainly leads to
biden leadership doesn't fully
understand also is rather frightened of
and we've got to get our act together
and that's what i've been trying to
explore and that's why i'm very pleased
to be on your program i want to talk i
think there's a bigger conversation a
worldwide conversation is needed to sort
out how we go from here well it's
interesting when you talk about the um
olive branches extended by joe biden to
progressives you know what i think my
audience which is mostly progressive
um
did not feel as though there were really
too many olive branches i mean i'll give
i'll give you my perspective at the time
which was yes i voted for joe biden i
believed that on paper joe biden ran on
the most progressive platform of any
democratic nominee i mean if you look at
obama in 2012 there and hillary in 2016.
on paper for what joe biden was
promising it was to the left of that to
some degree but also there was this
feeling that he his heart really wasn't
in a lot of the things he was sort of
agreeing to like for example joe biden
talked about maybe some student loan
forgiveness i didn't believe for a
second that that was really something
biden was interested in and he's really
not done anything on it cannabis
decriminalization or legalization he
sort of paid a little bit of lip service
to it
i didn't think he really cared about
that and he's not really taking any
action on it other than i think about a
hundred people uh whose records have
been expunged for for cannabis related
crimes or something like that so i went
in there with eyes wide open
knowing that this was the better option
i voted for him i think he's done some
good things but at the same time i i
don't know that the majority of my
progressive audience feels as though the
olive branches were serious or that
they've been followed through on
yeah well i think this is this is right
but i think that so there's different
things here there's biden himself i
think the vine himself
was actually shocked by
trump's uh willingness to reach out to
fascists and i don't think biden is a
racist i think that's really important
and i think that his he genuinely
was pleased to put a black woman in the
supreme court i think that he does
believe in in integration he is he's a
multi-racial figure i mean that's a very
deep and a very important issue and i
think that he reached out with his heart
wasn't in it but the point was and what
he stated and he understood is that
without the support of the
transformative promise
of the of the bernie sanders movement he
wouldn't have won
so is that i guess progress even if it
was cynical it's still coming from my
point of view of from our point of view
we've got to say okay okay right we've
got something going for us here right of
course we're not looking biden is a
creature of the american political
establishment yeah
of the last 40 years he pre-dates
neoliberalism he predates the
marketization but um and and we've
there's got to be a big generational
change taking place so so okay we've got
some strength here and how do we build
on this strength and i think one of our
problems has been one of the problems in
america but it's also a problem here in
the uk is too much looking at the
president at the center you know the the
right built its strength on the in the
states it built its strength locally
so it's building locally as well
we've got to be able to del there are
there's a very big progressive caucus in
the in the congress and i made a short
film called u.s progressives on the
knife edge i went to washington to
investigate the argument of my book to
test it if you like i talked to
a representative jamie raskin i talked
to pramila jayapal who's the chair of
the congressional
um
progressive caucus and i talked to
representative ro kahana who represents
silicon valley from california and they
were very interesting and articulate and
reaching out it seemed to me these are
not kind of you know um
they're seeking to gain popular support
but there isn't a progressive gathering
of governors of the us states
there's a weakness our weakness isn't
just oh well look biden isn't delivering
for us it's we've got to think okay this
is really serious we're up against
fighting we're not going to stop this
guy
and and those forces we've got to build
the alternative in a way that's credible
and build on that majority
in terms of building and alliances you
you talk about
the need for the progressive left to
ally with centrists to achieve
substantive
progress in in some senses and i think
the question of alliances is an
interesting one it's also very different
depending on whether a country has a
parliamentary system with proportional
representation or a system like the
united states or whatever the case may
be when it comes to
or i guess even thinking about it more
broadly
if the centrists
don't really want the things the
progressives want who's compromising in
those alliances
yeah well this is a very good question
one thing which i think is shifting is
that
they are beginning to understand that
without being in alliance with
progressives the center is going to lose
that's a very big shift
up until now whether it was under blair
or clinton or bill clinton or even obama
they felt they didn't need they felt
they didn't need the left they all they
needed was corporate power and corporate
support and corporate competence and
that would be enough and they could
they could rely upon the quiescence
of the population trump has made voting
count he's empowered his supporters and
unless
the the forces the democratic forces
that are opposed to trump unless we
empower our supporters we're finished
and that empowerment if you take the the
supreme court decision right on row
now what does a woman right to choose
mean in my view a woman's right to
choose is
their right to life
i think life is about choice i think one
of the extraordinary things about that
larger feminist movement is that it
empowers all of us i think men included
in in in in greater control over our
lives and one of the great historic
problems of the center and the liberals
that you talk to is they just say we'll
give you a bit of welfare we'll give you
some me maybe we'll give you students
though maybe we won't but whatever it is
you've got to be passive
they rely upon our passivity and i think
that trump has shown that that game is
over so we need to build on that and i i
think that we've got to be thinking
afresh but my argument it's not that i'm
an optimist
it's that we haven't lost yet and we
need to think about what the forces the
positive forces that there are and i
think that this sense of saying okay
we're going to show you what democratic
empowerment is really about
we uh in in the few minutes we have left
i want to talk a little bit about the
next two to four years you know in uh
many in the media always like to say
this is the most interesting important
and significant election of our time
because it benefits the media because
that sounds interesting but in i've used
this example before in 2012 in the
united states when mitt romney was
challenging barack obama's re-election i
i voted for barack obama and i thought
he was the better choice but it didn't
feel like it was the most consequential
election of our time it was sort of like
yes taxes on the rich will go down a
little bit if mitt romney wins and he's
socially conservative and i'm not but it
didn't feel as though there was as much
riding on it we now have a situation
where boris johnson resigning in the uk
the rise of the right-wing nationalist
parties in europe we have now in 2022
here in the united states the first
trump-era election where trump is not
president nor on the ballot and there's
this real question as to whether his
constituents will remain engaged in
politics or not and how that will relate
to 2024. i'm increasingly getting the
sense that the next election cycle or
two
in europe and the united states is
actually of major consequence in setting
the direction for the next decade or
more do you agree with that yeah i agree
with that completely this is the point i
was trying to make earlier i think that
trump now represents
a break from traditional republicanism
and this the january vi
demonstrated that the fact that they're
saying the election was stolen what does
this mean they don't there's not really
a denial that there was a seven million
plurality for bible what they're really
saying is the people who are voting we
don't count as americans
what they're saying it's an argument for
white supremacy it's not put in ex
explicitly racist terms but that's what
it's about it's about imposing minority
rule an imposing minority rule is a kind
of fascism it's an autocracy
and that's what's at stake now
what is the opposite of that and this is
the what's exciting if you like and grim
and interesting and as you say historic
is that we can't go back to clintonism
we can't go back to obama
those days are over partly because of
the financial crisis no everybody knows
that government is not the problem we
can't trust the market so so we've got
to
a choice is beginning to face historic
choices being forced on the united
states
either
trumpism
or a multi-explicitly multiracial
democratic future and that means
mobilizing and that means that without
progressives
the liberal center will lose
uh do you think that um at this point
what happens in the u.s
is as influential on what happens in
europe and vice versa as at prior times
has the
uh linkage been softened or made more
explicit
well that's also
a very interesting question so american
hegemony over europe has lessened
american hegemony in the world america
is still the
the strongest and most powerful country
in the world militarily and economically
the dollar is still supreme but it's no
longer rules the world in the way it did
that's primarily thanks to china
and that's a good thing in my view so in
one sense europe is now more important
than it was but if america goes fascist
if america embraces trump or desantis
and goes for minority rule and allies in
effect with a putin with xi and china
with the auth
against the european union
then uh the effect will be devastating
so this historic turning point of this
coming cycle between now and 2024
um is absolutely crucial for all of us
around the world united states is still
the hinge country and the choice you're
facing is still a choice that will
affect the entire world and the future
of the planet
uh those are those are sizable stakes
that's that's for sure we've been
speaking with anthony barnett who has
just published taking control humanity
and america after trump and the pandemic
anthony really a pleasure speaking with
you today really a pleasure thank you
very much david take care